I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE EVERYBODY THAT LIVES
IN MASSACHUSETTS AND GIVE THEM A NEW HAT!
That's a terrible idea
Howdy deciders and hunger-queens, this is
DNews; I'm Trace!
When you're hungry, your body makes all sorts
of changes, chemically and physically to make
sure everything continues to work properly;
we've talked about it a bunch on DNews.
You change how your metabolism works, whether
your stomach is going to produce acids, and
if left long enough your brain starts to break
down your own body.
It's actually kinda nuts.
Eating food is basically the main job for
a living organism, except of course, gettin'
it on.
But both of those things require a solid grasp
of the world around you, which, ironically,
is super impaired when you're hungry.
It's almost like we get hunger goggles.
According to a new study in Neuropsychopharmacology
the body releases a hormone called ghrelin
(GREL-in) when we're hungry that makes people
more impulsive.
Ghrelin and leptin are hormones which regulate
hunger and satiation.
Ghrelin is released from the gastrointestinal
tract, telling your body EAT EAT EAT!
Then, as the stomach stretches, leptin is
released from fat cells telling your body
Fuuuuuullll….
Fuuuuulllll…
To make us eat, ghrelin triggers the hypothalamus
-- which releases gastric acids and the muscles
that move food through your gastrointestinal
tract.
If you don't eat, ghrelin levels go up, and
up, and eventually, according to this new
research, its presence increases impulsivity!
JUST EAT ALREADY, it's saying.
But impulsiveness to eat, doesn't just affect
food intake.
It also can spill over into the rest of your
life, causing us all to make bad decisions.
In the scientific community, impulsivity is
so serious, it's considered an indication
of some neuropsychiatric disorders!
According to a study in Psychiatry Research,
people who are impulsive don't associate making
good decisions with reward, or bad decisions
with punishment.
For example, a study in the Journal of Neuroscience
scanned the brains of people asked to make
a decision, and provided them with the hormone
dopamine -- also linked to impulsivity.
The people who were more impulsive would take
a small sum of money right now, rather than
the (obviously better) large sum of money
later.
In fact, impulsivity caused 30 percent more
people to take the small sum now!
If you connect these two studies you'd see
that hunger makes you impulsive and being
impulsive makes you a worse decision maker;
thus, simply being hungry can keep us from
acting in our own best interest.
And if that weren't enough, when you're hungry,
you are likely feeling hunger pangs -- or
pain!
A study in PLOS One, found acute pain made
people more self-interested and of course,
more likely to get angry.
Combine that with impulsivity and you're just
a mess of poor decision making, says most
research.
THERE IS ONE BENEFIT though.
Impulsive, panged, decision-making may help
you when gambling.
In a single PLOS One study, they looked at
a small group of people who'd been fasting,
and had them gamble.
Those who were hungry, and supposedly more
impulsive: performed better on a gambling
game, than those who were satiated… though
they didn't know exactly why…
In the end, the science seems to say making
decisions on an empty stomach is a bad decision.
If you're hungry right now, go have a snack,
and then decide whether you believe me.
If you're hungry for more from DNews, you're
not alone.
So, with that in mind we launched a brand
new website: Seeker.com.
There, you can find allllll of DNews’ over
2400 episodes, plus original articles, photos,
and more great videos about science, the world,
politics, and even adventure and exploration.
It's flippin' awesome.
Click the link in the description to check
it out, and if you like it, help us spread
the word!
It's brand new!
Thanks.
But back to your stomach.
You're probably thinking, what about getting
'hangry,' where does that come in?
Oh, it comes in all right, and rocks you like
a hurricane.
Go feed yourself Seymour, and learn about
how we get hangry in
this video.